welcome back to a men's beauty edition
of drew's news that's right it's dude
news
where we serve the stories sunny side
that's right xana what dude beauty news
you got okay let's start with harry
styles who completely broke the internet
he just made vogue history by being the
first
male solo on the cover i can't believe
it's only just happened but he did it in
a gucci dress paired with the tuxedo
it was mega and everyone is going wild
over it it's all about gender neutral
looks
ugh he is so adorable and i
you know bowie all of it it just like
harkens back
to some really really beautiful men with
a lot of talent and a lot of um
presents so i love this and you know
what the rulebook is on fire so
magazines play and speaking of vogue uh
they report that gender lines are
disappearing in the beauty space too
and the beauty industry is valued at 532
billion dollars globally but men only
make up
one percent of sales men have been left
out
and now they're being marketed to and
with more men at home online and curious
about self-care
brands are reaching out to them zanna
you brought up a point that really blew
my mind you know why because we're all
on zoom calls all day long and men
are now looking at themselves in the
little box on their call
and like they never would have before
you don't walk into a meeting with a
mirror in front of you now suddenly men
are looking at the reflection
all day long and they're realizing maybe
i need a moisturizer maybe i need a
serum maybe i need some flower beauty
you know it's so interesting to me
because women
obsess in the mirror maybe now
then it's gonna happen to you oh my gosh
welcome to our world
okay drew we've got one very last bit of
very uplifting news
what's it yahoo life reports the beauty
industry is moving away from single-use
products like disposable sheet masks
skin care company duda is offering
reusable eye masks
that you wash and use again so basically
they don't come pre-soaked
with any formulation on them you just
add whatever you have at home it's
better for the environment
and your wallet also you can pick your
favorite product and it really
helps pack it in there and this
is you know listen i think this story
really spoke to me
this product really speaks to me we'll
have it on our website
but when you realize after the
phenomenon
of sheet masks that maybe they're not
best in practice for the environment
it's a real wake-up call it's gonna be a
massive wake-up call and i'm definitely
gonna be trying these
yeah no these are incredible all right
[Music]